bottomless and mysterious the sky
twinkling down on us with thousands of
stars has enchanted people since the
beginning of times
curiosity has always pushed mankind to
explore new expanses and break new
grounds
eventually the thirst for knowledge and
the technological progress enabled us to
start exploring beyond our native planet
this step stirred scientists curiosity
still more and very soon new space
wanderers left the earth to travel to
different corners of the solar system
and even further
they were devoid of emotions and senses
of either doubt or fear for these scouts
of the universe were machines
[Music]
cosmo
the first in outer space
roughly half a year before this video
was posted on the 15th of april 2021 the
automatic space probe new horizons
became the fifth spacecraft in the
history of the humanity to go beyond the
point of 50 astronomical units from the
sun
it was the voyages that had crossed this
mark before were the probes pioneer 10
and pioneer 11 the first ever to do so
none of these space wanderers are likely
to ever return to the earth
with some of them still active on their
missions others have gone quiet forever
spacecraft
new horizons
start of mission 19th of january 2006
distance to earth 52 astronomical units
speed
14 kilometers per second or three
astronomical units per year
main goal pluto and sharon
mission status successfully completed
condition operational
just like most other interplanetary
space probes new horizons performed a
gravity assist maneuver near jupiter
before setting out to its target
not only did it greatly boost the
spacecraft's speed but also allowed it
to capture high quality images of the
largest planet in the solar system
alongside its satellites
besides the probe's cameras captured the
first video ever of an erupting volcano
on the surface of jupiter's satellite io
after the gravity boost had been
completed the probe made for the main
target
pluto
the spacecraft reached the planetoids
environs in january 2015. the mission's
main goal was to explore pluto and
sharon from different perspectives that
involved taking photos of and mapping
these remote space object surfaces
in addition the probe estimated the
magnetic fields values and the solar
wind activity close to the objects and
collected information about their
atmospheres and surface reflection
properties
it goes without saying that the program
also involved search for pluto's as yet
undetected satellites and more accurate
measurements of pluto's orbits
parameters
having completed the main mission the
probe continued to be useful
it flew beyond pluto's orbit and went on
to explore objects in the kuiper belt
that is how images of kawa r1 and
darakoth were produced
thanks to the probe's cameras the
distances to the star's proxima centauri
and wolf 359 were measured
unfortunately the radio isotope
generator on board the spacecraft is
expected to start running low from 2026
and eventually all the meters will
switch off one after another
new horizons will continue on its way
beyond the boundaries of the solar
system and by the year 2038 the distance
between the probe and the sun will have
grown to be a hundred astronomical units
by that time the energy generator on
board the spacecraft will have stopped
operating completely and it will be
impossible to get any connection with it
following a hyperbolic orbit new
horizons will exit our system never to
come back
the same thing happened with two other
probes pioneer 10 and pioneer 11.
they hit an escape trajectory from the
solar system a while ago
in fact they were the first automatic
space probes ever to be sent into
interstellar space by humans
spacecraft pioneer 10
start of mission
3rd of march 1972 distance to earth
127 astronomical units speed
approximately 12 kilometers per second
or two and a half astronomical units per
year
main goal jupiter
mission status successfully completed
condition not operational
the spacecraft reached jupiter's system
on the 4th of december 1973 after
completing a
641-day journey through space
during the mission images of the gas
giant's surface and its largest
satellites were beamed back to the earth
and the planet's atmospheric composition
and magnetic field were gauged in
addition jupiter was found to emit two
and a half times more thermal energy
than it receives from the sun the data
unique at the time became the basis for
understanding the makeup of gas giants
and their satellites
the trajectory of the second probe
pioneer 11 through space passed jupiter
2 but its main target was the other gas
giant of our system
saturn
the probe's scientific instruments
gauged the planet's magnetic field and
the cameras on board took quite a few
snapshots not only of the gas giant
itself and its system of rings but also
two of its satellites titan and mimos
according to the estimates the current
distance between pioneer 11 and the
center of our system is around 106
astronomical units on completing their
main mission both probes continued on
their way moving further and further
away from the sun
unfortunately both of them are out of
range now with the last signal from
pioneer 10 received back in 2003
the last signal from pioneer 11 was
received in 1995.
supposedly both of them are now rapidly
moving beyond the boundaries of the
solar system
incidentally having no chance of ever
catching up with either of the two
probes we're going to talk about next
the pioneers were launched at a much
earlier date
spacecraft voyager 1
start of mission
5th of september 1977
distance to earth
154
astronomical units
speed
around 17 kilometers per second or 3.6
astronomical units per year
main goal jupiter and saturn
mission status
successfully completed
condition
not fully operational
the contribution of voyager 1 to the
solar system's exploration can hardly be
overestimated
it is thanks to this probe that several
new jupiter satellites were discovered
alongside its ring system which was big
news
the voyager's cameras captured volcano
eruptions on io and provided hard
evidence that jupiter's great red spot
is an enormous storm
the probe beamed back hundreds of photos
of the largest planet of our solar
system and its satellites
after the spacecraft crossed neptune's
orbit the meters on board sent back a
great amount of valuable data about
interstellar plasma voyager 1 left both
the kuiper belt and the heliopause
behind a long while ago and is now
rapidly crossing the area of the solar
system's scattered disc
making for the inner boundary of the
hypothetical oort cloud it is not only
the remotest man-made object in space
but also the fastest of all the
spacecraft on their way to exit our
system
being the first space probe to have
traveled that far from the center of the
solar system
voyager 1 offered scientists a unique
opportunity to study the heliopause
this is the area around our sun where
solar wind pressure and interstellar gas
pressure balance when the charged
particles emitted by the star collide
with rarefied plasma elaborate
structures form out of elementary
particles and magnetic fields
studying them is crucial for
understanding processes taking place in
the universe
unfortunately by around the year 2025
the power of the radioisotope
thermoelectric generators on board the
probe will have run out completely and
the connection will have been lost in
300 years voyager 1 is estimated to
reach the inner boundary of the
hypothetical oort cloud it will take the
spacecraft approximately thirty thousand
years to go clean through
and after that it will fly beyond the
boundaries of the solar system ten
thousand years later still the probe
will fly by the star glieser 445 at a
distance of 1.6 light years and then it
will eventually get lost in the infinite
depths of outer space
[Music]
speaking about voyager 1 we can't but
mention its twin launched from the earth
on the 20th of august 1977.
voyager 2 had saturn uranus and neptune
for its targets but it also approached
jupiter for a gravity boost it's the
images taken by this probe that allowed
scientists to assume that there are
subsurface oceans on ganymede and europa
on reaching saturn
voyager 2 gauged the gas giant's
temperature and magnetic field and
discovered several new satellites it
goes without saying that lots of
snapshots were taken of both saturn's
surface and its rings
next in line on the probe's way were
uranus and neptune
the flyby yielded a great number of
unique snapshots and in total 17 of the
two planet satellites were discovered
also it was found that both uranus and
neptune have ring systems
under neptune's gravitational influence
the spacecraft changed its trajectory
and left the ecliptic plane
this meant that voyager 2 wouldn't be
able to approach the other objects in
the solar system but it still had other
exciting things to look forward to thus
the probe was to collect invaluable data
about interstellar plasma and cosmic
wind as well as to measure distances to
stars and explore the heliosphere
the probe is currently as far as 128
astronomical units away from the center
of our system with a distance growing by
15.37 kilometers every second
it's going to take it around 42 000
years to approach ross 248
a dim red dwarf in the constellation
andromeda
the minimal distance between voyager 2
and the star will be about 1.7 light
years and around 300 000 years since its
launch chances are it will fly by sirius
at a distance of 4.3 light years
unfortunately it is impossible to
distinguish such a tiny object from the
earth that far away
we live at the dawn of space exploration
and interplanetary space probes are just
mankind's first timid steps in exploring
the infinite universe
it is hard to predict their fate
they may be smashed on collision with
the celestial body or they may be
recaptured by our distant descendants
who will have advanced interstellar
travel technologies to the point of
being able to catch up with the probes
for all we know they might recover them
from space and put on display in a
museum
but it is more likely that the fragile
apparatuses are destined to drift on for
years and years through the lifeless
expanses
and millions of years later
radioactive rays and rare particles of
cosmic dust whizzing through the probes
time and time again will eventually wear
them down to threadbare debris to be
scattered across the depths of the
universe without a trace
you